foreign
there has been a significant and
successful expansion of computer vision
research in recent years much of this
success can be attributed to the
adoption and the adaption of machine
learning
While others can be attributed to the
invention of innovative representation
and models for specific computer vision
issues object detection is the one area
that has made significant Improvement
hello everyone I am mayank and welcome
to Simply learn today we will take you
through a hands of lab demo of how to do
object detection using opencv for
amazing videos like this subscribe to
our YouTube channel and press the Bell
icon to stay updated so
in today's session we will discuss what
opencv is and moving ahead we will see
what is object detection and at the end
we will do a hands of live demo of
object detection using opencp in fact
study says there will be more than 2.3
billion job openings in the field of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning by 2023 but you can beat the
curve with a professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning
co-sponsored by Purdue University and
IBM which is designed after simply an
intense bootcamp learning model AI
animal certification code this course
covers tools and techniques like python
tensorflow Keras and ltk and many more
along with industry project like social
media by Twitter delivery service
provider by zomato transportation
service provider by Uber and many more
Amazing projects so choosing this course
you can get hired on renowned companies
like Google Amazon LinkedIn and Adobe
and an average salary high cost 70
percent so what are you waiting for join
the AI and ml certificate program and
Excel your year in artificial
intelligence the link is in the
description box below before starting
let us have a simple question to brush
up your knowledge so opencv stored RGB
pixels in word order gbr RGB vgr and vrg
please answer in the comment section
below and we will update the current
answer in the pin comments or you can
pause the video give it a thought and
answer in the comment section before we
move on to the programming part let's
discuss what opencvs and proceed further
for the same
opencv open source computer vision
library is an open source computer
vision and machine learning software
Library it is written in C plus plus but
has a binding for various programming
languages such as python Java Matlab
opencv was designed with a goal of
providing a common infrastructure for
computer vision applications and to
accelerate the use of machine learning
perception in commercial product opencv
is widely used in a variety of
Industries including robotics automotive
and Healthcare it's supported by a large
community of developers researchers and
users who contribute to its development
and provide supports to its users it is
supported by a large community of
developers researchers and users who
contribute to its development and
provide supports to its users so now
let's see what is object detection
object detection is a computer vision
technology that involves identifying and
localizing the object of interest within
an image or a video it is a challenging
task as it involves not only recognizing
the presence of an object but also
detecting its precise location and size
within the image or video object
detection algorithm typically used deep
learning techniques such as CNN to
analyze the image or video for
identifying the objects these algorithm
can also determine the boundaries of the
object by drawing a bounding box around
them so after understanding what is
object detection now let's move on to
the programming part so this is a kernel
python kernel here we will change this
name
so here I will write object
detection
demo
okay
so
first we will import some major Library
like opencv so for that we will write
import CV2 and the next one is import
matplotlab
dot Pi plot
as PLT
so why we are writing PLT because we
can't write again and again matplotlib
dot pipelot okay it's a long one so we
can write a short form PLT
so yeah
so let's run this
so what is opencv opencv is an open
source software library for computer
vision and machine learning opencv full
form is open source computer vision
Library it was created to provide a
shared infrastructure for application
for computer vision and to speed up the
use of machine learning perception in
consumer products opencv has a BSD
license software make it simple for
companies to use and change the code
okay so there are some predefined
packages and libraries that make our
life simple and opencv is one of them
second one is matte broadly matte
bloodlib is a easy to use and an amazing
visualize library in Python it is built
on numpy array and designed to work with
broader sci-fi stack and consists of
several plots like line bar scatter
histogram and many others okay so moving
forward we will import our file okay so
here I will write config
file
equals to this is our file name SSD
underscore
mobilenet
to V3
large
Coco
22.
14 dot BB
okay
so you can find this file in the
description box below
Frozen
model
question
so I'll explain you
every single thing
inference
graph
dot PB okay
so let me run it first
mobilenet as a name applied the mobile
net model is designed to use in mobile
application and its tensorflow first
mobile computer vision model mobile net
used depth wise separable convolutions
it significantly reduces the numbers of
parameter when compared to the network
with regular convolutions with the same
depth in the rights this result in the
lightweight of the deep neural network
so mobilenet is a class of CNN that was
open source by Google and therefore this
gives us an excellent starting point for
training our classifiers that are
insanely small and insanely fast okay so
what is this large Coco this is a data
set Coco data set like with applications
such as object detection segmentation
and captioning the Coco data set is
widely understood by the state of the
art of neural network its versatility as
a multi-purpose scene variations of best
to train a computer vision model and
Benchmark its performance okay so what
is Coco the common object in context is
one of the most popular large scale
labeled images data available for public
use it represents a handful of objects
we encounter on a daily basis and
contains Imaging notations in 80
categories I will show you the
categories I have with over 1.5 million
object instances okay so modern day AI
driven solution are still not capable of
producing absolute accuracy and result
which comes down to the fact that Coco
dataset is a major Benchmark for CV to
train test and polish refine models for
faster scaling of The annotation
Pipeline on the top of that the Coco
data set is a supplement to transfer
learning where the data used for one
model serves as a starting point for the
another so what is frozen Insurance
graph like freezing is the process to
identify and save all the required
graphs like weights and many others in a
single file that you can usually use a
typical tensorflow model contains four
file and this com contains a complete
graph okay so forward let's create one
model here I will add modern
CV2 dot DNN
model
chosen
and then
config file
so here I am giving the parameters two
parameters like frozen model and config
file
score here yeah you run it first
okay there is error written
okay so either this cv2.dnn detection
model returned as result
with an exception set
the question comes what is the meaning
of detection model or DNN detection
model for this class represent the high
level API for object detection networks
detection models allows to set
parameters for pre-processing input
image detection model creates net from
file and with trained weights and config
sets in processing input runs forward
pass and return the result detections
okay moving forward let's set the class
levels
class
labels
file name
txt
I will put this file on the description
box below you can download from there
open
file name
first labels
the strip
so here I created one array of name
class labels so this is the file name
what I am doing I am putting this label
file into this class label okay so here
if I will print
class labels
so these are the 80
categories in the Coco data set
okay this person bicycle car motorbike
airplane bus train these all are the 80
categories
I will put this file label.txt in the
description box below you can download
from them
okay fine
so let's print the length of the Coco
data set or you can see class labels
it is 80 as you can see I have already
told you
the length will be 80.
so here let's
set this some model input size scaling
mean and all so I will write here model
Dot
set
put
eyes
320 comma 20.
set
input
scale
1.0
0.5
okay I will explain you don't worry
model dot set
import
mean
127.5
comma 127.5
okay and then model
dot set
to web
B
will be
what is set input size
okay
so set input size is a size of new frame
the shape of the new blob Less Than Zero
okay so this is the size of the new
frame the second one is set input scale
the set input scale is a scale factor of
the value for the frame
or you can say the perimeter will be the
multiplier of the frame values or you
can say multiplier for the frame values
okay so at input mean so it set the mean
value for the frame the frame in which
the photo will come the video will come
on my webcam will come so it set the
mean value for the frame or the four
parameters mean scalar with the mean
values which are subtracted from the
channels you can say and the last one is
set input swap RB so it set the flag
swap RB for the every frame we don't
have to put every time a single frame
for a particular image it will be set
the true for the all the images okay so
parameters will be swipe I'll be flag
which indicates the swipe first and the
last channels so moving forward we will
put one image
M read
y dot jpg
Dot
I am sure
so this is the size of 320 by 320 okay
so first thing is
you can download this the random picture
from the Google I took from Google
itself so now what we will do
we will set the class index
the confidence value
box is the boundary box which I will
create for that particular person cycle
motorbike and the car
okay
because to model
kept
the confidence threshold
threshold is used for
if my model will confirm it's the
particular image which is detecting is
correct it will print the name
okay
so let me print
pass
class index is coming one two three four
okay so one means person
two means bicycle
3 means car and four means motorbike
this is the class index index for
particular level what I will do I will
print the boxes
font
here
equals to 3
and the font equals to CV2 Dot
font Hershey
again
for
class
plus index and then
confidence and the boxes
x dot atom
confidence
pattern
box the boundary box
okay
and I will write here CB2 dot rectangle
to make the rectangle
set the image
and boxes
I've
comma 0 comma zero
this is the color of the box and this
will be the thickness
okay then I will write CV2 dot put
text
image then
first labels
I will write class
index minus 1
because always index start with zero
that's fine and the boxes
zero
and
comma boxes
okay
and comma
scale
assume font
okay
color
question
this will be the text column
0 comma 255
comma 0
and the thickness
let me run it
I am sure
then CV2 dot CBT
color
then
comma CV T2
dot color
then vgr
to prg
that is why we wrote
swap RB equals to true because every
time we will convert BGR to brg
sorry
GB
RGB so we don't have to write again and
again it will convert all the files into
RGB okay run it
okay as you can see the motorbike is
coming
bicycle is coming the person is coming
the card will come the car is coming
okay so it's detecting the right
for the image now we will do this for
the video and for the webcam
we are done with this image one and then
now I will write here
okay
so this is we'll do for the video
for the video I will write here cap
equals to capture
you can write any name so CV2 Dot
video
capture
so you can take any random video I took
this pixels
George
you can comment down
share the link
before
F dot is open
so here I will add cap
equals to
be 2
sorry CV2
Dot video
capture
0.
0 and if not
cap
dot is open
then
and raise
output
error
and
open the video
and open the video
here everything will be the same font
scale
equals to 3
okay I want
equal to CV2 Dot
font
e
okay so here I will write while true
from a frame
equals to cap dot sheet
this for the reading of the file
the same I will write class index
comma confidence
from a boundary box
question model
dot detect
name
and the confidence
threshold
0.55
okay everything is the same
we did before so here I will print
class
index
okay
so here I will write if
and
the class index
does not equals to zero
then what to perform is here I have to
add 4
class index
comma confidence
comma boxes
and zip
Plus
x dot
flatten
flatten is a layers
okay
confidence
flatten
view box
and if
class
index is greater than equals to 80.
then
what to do then I will copy from here
okay the same thing I have to write here
so here I will write CV2 Dot
I am sure
this will be the return in the frame
object detection
by simply learn
and frame
so if CV2 Dot
weight key
to
and 0
f of x
equals to
Ord
Q
okay
then
here I will write Brink
will you break when
and get into two the weight key will be
2.
okay I will tell you what is the weight
key
so here I will write cap dot release
and CV2 Dot
destroy
or Windows
okay
so now let me run
it's here there will be error okay
modules
we run it again
activate keys
okay
so video is here
the video is here as you can see see
bicycle the person the person the bus
car traffic light the person person so
it our object detection for the video is
coming right okay person
okay person traffic light bus
this is how you can do for the video
okay
so now let's we will do for the webcam
live
so this is for the video so
if
we want to do for the webcam with
okay so we need to just change
one one thing only we have to change
instead of giving the file we have to
write one here
okay the rest will be the same
got it so I have to just shut down my
webcam
so
let me shut down the webcam and get back
to you
so as you can see
this is a 320 by 320 box so
so this is coming right okay so I if I
will show this the mobile phone is
coming right now okay so this is how you
can do the correct object detection okay
so if you enjoyed this video
and if you want this full code how to do
so you can comment for the same
okay if you want this full code you can
comment for the same one code and if you
have any queries related to python
machine learning you can comment for the
same
so if you enjoyed this video please do
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
press that Bell icon to never miss any
update from Simply learn till then thank
you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you